і сьогодні ми з Русланом кулею будемо
говорити
вона національний таз і крута
нібито раді витрачати пологовий будинок владу на
поштовою з того А що таке
національний мультипредмадний тест
національний мультиподяковість
за українською, а також третій предмет
можливо взяти та врахувати Будьте уваги
з історії України тут не через наземні
мух батька
французькою
біології
тут вибирається самі англоях розповімо
діставай на права столицею
води для вас і результати ви зможете
свої без знака, що це написано кнопку
класні коли та проходять
промоційність сьогодні ми з вами
говоримо училку тому що починається на
найважливіший етап підготовки
реєстрація реєстрація для участі
витінювання
до трекима травня зґвалтована після того
як ви заповнені у сірій стратегії форми
це за прохання перепустки для участі
покинута перепустка
це 28
результати
Ви можете
[музика]
реєстрація немає я вже призначила відривати
вас страхи клікня до третього рівня
так ми розуміємо що я крім приватні
які цифри
ви можете помилуватися за Курбанова по
ножами там годинник купоні території для
вас будуть доступні щоб надковий період
до 12 навчань.
доля
за вашим вибором
ніша ви зможете
реєстрація що це означає що вам не
буде потрібно
седані простого помідора у спеціальному
сервісі
на сайт українського центру оцінювання
документів
далі
вчаться
йти для прибирання регіональним центром
оцінювання
закінчити
Класно, що вимагатимуть
стратегій формі
виводити
що я дату народження дали документи
щоб свічки особу тут за рота це
лагідного реєстраційного номера
опубліковані карти щільно як зашморги
відсоток
електронну пошту а також потрібно буде
вас я доступно випускних Ось точно уроку
Це означає, що вицілу Руку
вичавлюватися
українською мовою
спеціальній формі далі
пункт в Україні через акордон Давай
попрацюємо це зараз проведено
національного мультипремального тесту
всю інформацію для того щоб вас на
дати вам таку вузли або прихованого тіні
національний мультипідприємець
водопроводи
крилах
український центр синього Світлана мати
інформацію
національні мультиплегматний таз може
бути розширеним
що вам потрібно
[музика]
реєстрації плюс штраф пара днів що вам
буде потрібно
що я такі збиткові документи
за паспортні документи
про те, що ви здуваєте повну середню
знизу кладемо сидить це процедурка носить
А от
свідчить
українського центру
я стрибнула будиночки
було зазначено так що самий виліт це
ваше Примарна я кубаньку і е випускний
комфо-точному уроку
Москва
реєстраційний номер опублікованої
карти платника подарунки Так що
називається в народі
може бути різьблених форм Покажіть
досвід щоб так
так вже якшу Ви та прикладу змінила
закликала і у вас документ про по
музичному середньому сміту виданий
слідувати питання міна імені чепець означає
працюємо на Даня спеціальних особуєвих
умів для проходження
форма спеціальний блок реєстрації
подати інформацію
фотографії цар документи форматі png А
ось gpg ті документи може бути
одного мегабайта за розміром
копій травня Будди
папаспорт книжечка
[музика]
свічку особливого НАТО кошманіст це
Примарний Якубович з ерект номер
паспорта число до місяця
ваш номер
опубліковані карти тесляра подарунки
в адміністративній формі такого
за монтажить її волосся
але у вас Внаслідок про народження за
монтаж Тут у неї може бути що церемор
винесений також до інсулу документу до
прикладу в паспорт громіздкий на
Україні
владного дикарті буде ласка Дайте
номер офіційно
пристойних документів для вас
натиснули я до шуби
Сама така ваш номер про КПП ми можемо його
зареєструвати
йому важливо вносити
Якось інформації
раннього світла у взутті швидку ми це на
дати нам скаче копію з ведуться просто
пластикові документи
як їх ви не треба ви якшу ви садиба
була правильно
І просить перевірити інформацію
[музика]
у своєму комбінаті у крем-ті інформатики
про сертифікат ніякої вже призначила ось
так вже побачите ти можеш вивести зради
ти у креймера і стратегії Дані з може
працювати до сьомга травня я кидання Ви
можете
ці кошики з-за кордону можуть працювати
основа мов Але це склади так вже
Може влаштовувати те що ви плану
це не хоче
Скільки зараз приховує відставання
що ви знаєте україни
нського центру
вам вигідно заходить, бо ми
вкладаємо
у 2020
а шалоні ступняки
директор українського центру тинування
Тетяна Вакуленко розпалила вам проте я
потрібно рестроватоса для страждання
національного мультипредметного тесту
2020 третього уроку
реєстрація національного тесту такий вже
містості одне інтелектуальне завдання
Для вас
логіку
я хочу вам показати формулу конкурсного
стадії
ви боїтеся формулу конкурсного балу Я
думаю ви вона вже знаємо вона складається
з двох частим з основної частини Якщо ви
хрестовується коефіцієнти у грі
коефіцієнти про предмети та результати
складання національного тесту
мова за математики і з третього вибирає
А що вони йдуть параметри Які ви
можете ці знаки у своїх закладах
західних речовин таких висновків виступати за
за успішне закиньшине біля їхньої стопи
Підготуйте в курсі закладу ви зараз
бачите про такий же голосові коефіцієнти
та регіональні Ну чоловік момент коли
мене заяв для супу будуть вже різні рахунок
за коефіцієнти і чим це на них
наше заміж сьогодні завдання
сину конкурсу
математичний прийом хочу показати я
можна в тому кінці конкурсний бал
Уявіть
свердловинний коефіцієнт з трьох з комор
відомо тики до двох
складаю інформацію
[музика]
до будинку або піднімається
психопатії і в принципі можна було б ми
не показувати А ви все-таки де Просто
ти дихання ми проходимо до формули Ека А
у наведеному діє
формули конкурсного
баладанів порядку прийому хочеш
повернутися вашу вологу очністю формулу
ті формули
рахунок тут важливий більше піти у формулі
відтінки 2
просиш вона
оцінку за третій предмети
і ту ж схожу на вагові коефіцієнт
третього предметів
і дзвонити вашій бабусі сума богових
коефіцієнтів
Росії національного
і при уфології вашого рішення
вибір третього предмета вам говорять для
шкірних спеціальностей зароблю отинку
даних, що звучить У вас є і ваша
пана
син двох підприємців не тільки що
підтягнутостей потенціал не може при
виборі одного
цих підприємницького блоку третього
ця частка собі зникла ось цю форму вже
так вона наочно і хоче повернутися в
вашу
зокрема коефіцієнти нехай у нас
коефіцієнт тертя
після коефіцієнт агрокований у сумі та
ми йому вибрано на екрані для вас третє
а ті з вас хто захоче
математичні формули будуть
у тому, що у нас є
налаштовуйте коефіцієнти, що ти кажеш
забезпечити підривання головного
зоорального ніж вищий коефіцієнт
третьому предмети
Ви можете розробити
спеціальності на призначення стоїть
вона приймає 0,5 Це означає, що ви
можете
вибрали з прикрас
відтінку української мови математики
тому що
вагони коефіцієнт підприємством предметі
доросла оком зростанням катри
собачих графіку
ще одне приватне зростання тіло
бічного коефіцієнта менше
коефіцієнти за інший тип
українську
математику іоціє так завдання
лише від іншої натинки за українську
мова так математику і що ж вона буде
раніше логіка увійшов
від нього кажуть що
проводиться тоді з позбавлення жодних
самостріл
йти
якогось на українське море
ваших вчителів
формули ці графіки вона знаєте ми не
будемо вказати завдання
а я хотів
формулі самі такі хто міг як ми
мотивуємо у вас до вибратися звідси
формула конкурсного балу орієнтована на
стику на профільного предмета знижки на
демонстрацію вступником кращих у
результаті
чому так Хто каша буду повністю на
профільні предмет Польща
профільний предмет можна однозначно
для багатюг спеціальності профільні
підприємець може бути і
неоднозначним А можна було під цим
спеціальностях у нас правда
для українського математика
ціни вибір профільного підприємця
цілі групи предметів за цим просто
чоловіка
та труднощі на практиці кожна людина
кое-ступних двадцять третьому уроці
вигаданою один третій
Ну можна здавши, але можна в 23 рік за
розкриватися з класів 2 цих фрагментів
такі осолтекви щоб новини проводили
національним ультраматному тесту 203
в Рік військового
1001 год
наземної філології то ситуація
вона спеціальності наземної англійської
я думаю що всі зрозумілі повністю
цим третім предметом вступати на боді
його спеціально аце означає що ми не
можемо поставити якони було в нижчі
критерії це-профільної
головним критерієм у нас чи
готовності
Я думаю що на багатих людей без знання
ведуть
все-таки Виходимо зі здорового блузку
почали
спеціально
наземного може бути на багатих то вона
точно по виносить його шансів будь-що
хочемо це інші
важливі
Найкраще результат досягається заради
вибору третього предмету зотинку вище
загроговану картинку української мови
та математика
за українську мову там математики кожен
чувакси Думатимуть третього предмета
не з максимальним коефіцієнтом
мінімальним ваговим коефіцієнтом для
щоб призначення то результат ці
ось
іншого не отіть українські
таке інше
щоб не може
визначати
між українською тематикою А тут вид
ніж не в протилежному коефіцієнті Я
думаю вимочуватися у формулі хтось
диван доводяться просто взяті багатого
взято ручку огірки за екран монітора
загадати ще у школі Excel А ви просто
взято калькулятор І
взагалі раніше
національне мультипідприємництво
так мало
дуже думати його міняти
собі апарат вирушив
повністю раціонально повністю слідова
інтуїції
для виграшних конкурсних боїв за
семантикалова для вас спеціальністю
хоча б зазначити ще стілець 2023
за заплаченим вже графіком
ще розкладу цього нмт в основному
спеціальності для творчого конкурсу
може в принципі на цій ховатися для
створення національного тесту а будуть
складатися тики творчий корпус їжі
на прошу про канат Якщо ще знаєтесь
коли спеціальності з творчістю та з
каната сили абсолютно в повній У чому
рішенні вищого все-таки красивіше зараз
розкривач казки його та Матір собі
дудостковий варіант
о 20:00
про пороги як я слово
абсолютно реальним і ввічливим а при
складанні національного ультра
предметного застигання які будуть
збуватися
вашу маму мінімальний позитивний бал
національного
предметів так само як там будуть
страхуватися все щоб ніяких до
магістратури Свободи також протистоять на
складових єдинопочаткового чи щось
крижаного фахопного промивання
досягаєте
тестових лазнях те що вимивається
набратися до 10.500 праворуч
при схилі
національному це предметного тесту для
результат ще вашого чилка була 100 баре
коли в принципі могла вступати в
результатом до закладу
а менше того А в ступорі проведенні на
бюджет може вийти петунії ваш
конкурсний бал з Потаємним менше 100
відсотків
Я хочу повернутися до вашої лагунації Ммм я
пишу вас знімати 130 балів ви не будуть
вираховані на бюджет знайти
ви знаєте готувати в роботі А ви не
лише 130 Балі для дітей загиблих
зафісноків України думаю ми не дарма по
ясливають чого ми вибираємо Star
заробити не так ви мені особливого
моді для ступняки на український тягар
конкурсний бал для ступу на основі
повній зоні середнього і
спеціаліста підсилювач
професіоналам мета нас позначає всіх
національну рамки кваліфікації
Менше 140 барів на бюджет і не менше
для супу на спеціальності
право 27 громадського управління це
адміністраціями 29 міжнародні видосами
226 форматі
форматі
Ну напишемо Суворова поріг ціль для ступу
нам з особистої спеціальності та неофітним
конкурсний бал доступ на основі повної
зоні середнього світу А ось 5 лінії
національної рамки кваліфікації
більшою мірою для спеціальності 221
стоматологія 222 медицина 223
Я вважаю
з нас хоче
кваліфікації та високому часу